Anna Faris and Charlize Theron hit the
big screen this weekend with overboard
and Tully and if you haven't seen
Avengers infinity war yet are you doing
it was so good this is your weekend
ticket Anna Faris has big top-siders to
fill in her remake of the 1987 Kurt
Russell Goldie Hawn classic overboard
what's a Top Sider in this version Anna
plays the role of the disgruntled
employee pulling a fast one over her
wealthy yacht owning boss played by a
Lohan Yoder best who is struck with
amnesia and poor yep duty to look like
me we had to use the sperm donor this
movie is for you if you love the
original overboard you're a fan of the
finely tuned comedic wit of Anna Faris
or if you own a yacht in any case this
certainly is a must see remaking such a
fan favorite classic can be a huge task
but luckily for Anna Curtin Goldie
invited her to dinner and after a
grueling vetting process they gave her
their blessing this weekend Charlize
Theron hits the big screen as a
different kind of atomic blonde more of
a mother of three who gets a night nanny
kind in the latest from Focus Features
Tulley no no no
Tulley is the name of the night nanny
who comes to the rescue to help Charlize
Theron's scare achter Marlo with simple
things like nanny stuff and coping with
middle aged motherhood reality I hold a
baby all day and then night time rolls
around and I'm supposed to just switch
gears like hello I'm all sexy now you're
empty yeah the great cast showcases the
talents of a bunch of people you know
you've seen in everything but can't put
your finger on it like Mackenzie Davis
says Tully from the Martian and Blade
Runner 2049 mark Duplass from the league
and safety not guaranteed and Ron
Livingston from office space written by
Diablo Cody the writer of Juno and
Jennifer's Body Tully is for you if you
like perky Indy
slice-of-life films you're a mom looking
for a movie that's maybe too real and
maybe too honest or if you enjoy the
full range of the talented Charlize
Theron interestingly enough Charlize
actually gained 50 pounds for this role
which was both a physical and mental
challenge
she said the unhealthy diet required to
gain the weight often made her feel
lethargic and tired mom what's wrong
with your body
finally I probably don't have to remind
you but Avengers infinity war came out
last week and it certainly needs to be
at the top of your list if you haven't
seen it I loved it 24 times a second I
loved it who made this amount of money
that was so special be a part of
something that was making people feel
like they were celebrating there was a
celebration to have and that is your
weekend ticket check back next week for
melissa mccarthy's tramper return to
college in life of the party
and while you're here leave a comment
what's your favorite 80s remake oh no
not the dust
[Music]